TUCKER?
>> TUCKER CARLSON: TRACE
GALLAGHER, THE BEST.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> TUCKER CARLSON: YOU MAY NOT
HAVE NOTICED.
HE PULLED THE TOP-RATED ANCHOR
CHRIS CUOMO OFF OF THE AIR FOR
HELPING HIS BROTHER.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW AHEAD OF TIME,
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE PEOPLE
TUNING IN SAYING, WAIT, WHERE'S
THE STEROID GUY.
SO WITH THE NEWS THAT CHRIS
CUOMO WAS BEING PULLED OFF
INDEFINITELY SUSPENDED.
WHAT'S SO INTERESTING, IT TELLS
YOU VERY MUCH ABOUT CNN THAT HE
WOULD HIMSELF WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
HIS JOB.
OH, THE BETRAYAL.
SO INTERESTING.
SO, THE QUESTION, WHAT KIND OF
PERSON IS CNN'S MEDIA CRITIC?
WE COME ACROSS AUDIO THAT
ANSWERS A QUESTION.
SO HERE -- WE'RE GOING TO USE
HIS NAME FOR THE FIRST TIME,
BRIAN STELTER, EXPLAINING TO A
GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT HE HAS
FIRED HIS NAME, HE REMAINS
NAMELESS BECAUSE SHE REFUSED TO
GET THE INJECTION.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> ME AND MY WIFE WORK FULL
TIME, WE ARE OUT DURING THE DAY
IN NEW YORK AND OUR NANNY
REFUSED TO GET VACCINATED.
WE'RE PARTING WAYS WITH HER.
IT WAS VERY, VERY SAD.
THAT WE THOUGHT AFTER SIX MONTHS
THAT EVERYTHING IS FINE.
>> TUCKER CARLSON: SO THE
HEADLINE HERE IS THAT CNN'S
MEDIA CRITIC DISMISSED, BLYTHELY
DISMISSED HIS NONWHITE SERVANT
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T OBEY AND
THAT'S, QUOTE, VERY, VERY SAD.
HOW SAD WAS HE, EXACTLY?
DID HE PAY HER HEALTH INSURANCE
UNTIL SHE FINDS A NEW JOB?
WHAT IS SHE DOING TO EAT AND PAY
HER RENT NOW THAT SHE'S BEEN
DISMISSED BY CNN'S VERY SAD
MEDIA CRITIC?
WE DON'T CARE WHAT HAPPENED TO
OUR SERVANTS, DO THEY?
WHEN THEY DISOBEY.
WE ASKED CNN TODAY, WE GOT NO
ANSWER AT ALL, WHICH IN ITSELF
AN ANSWER WHICH IS, WE DON'T